so you at our house so humble with these
well know I travel with these but I have
like desktop stands for them yeah so I
don't have like the arms and all that
kind of stuff but like yeah so this is
like the new home
you are rocking so a lot cast man you
are you know amazing well thanks for
coming by yeah I appreciate it you were
one of the early guests on the show I
don't know what number it was but it was
like way back in the day way back in the
day and you like took off right away I
mean it wasn't meaning you just like
soared right away it's cool here
actually maybe turn that up a little bit
see you're speaking into it that's cool
yeah perfect and I've had your lovely
bow on twice yeah so you were due to
come back with me Congrats on the new
book thank you 5,000 new book by
thousands much I told Dan let's just
let's just take a little breather and
sit out on the balcony and drink wine
and not write for about a year and yeah
well you're going to Switzerland next
week right yeah so that's cool except
Dan has to work right he's speaking at
Davos yeah he's speaking at Davos that's
crazy
unhappiness that's a pretty powerful
situation isn't it yeah I know I'm
nervous for him but he's such a great
speaker does he get nervous when he
speaks he doesn't look like it he looks
like he just he he looks like he's
winging it and having a great time and
yes nails it every time yeah he
practices a lot he he goes over his
notes a lot so he takes it seriously but
then once he's on he doesn't get nervous
right
you can tell yeah he's a pro he's well
he's I think he's born to do that he
loves like if you ever come to our house
for dinner he's the one who will
immediately stand up in a chair and give
a toast you know I've seen that you know
that he knows how to hold court he does
he holds court he should be giving some
we're all happy for him to do it yeah
totally I'm like do it I would be the
one on the sidelines clapping so well
cool it's great to have you here I want
to hear a little bit about what's going
on in Santa Barbara because we know
these crazy mudslides I know you're a
little bit out of the
of where the real damage is happening
but what's it like to be there and see
firsthand the devastation it is it is a
shock to the soul to see this stuff
manifest right in front of you you know
you're used to reading the paper and
seeing things happen and the hills of
Guatemala or you know rural China and to
know that there's a mudslide happening
in your town that just sucks people out
of their houses and it's killed I think
the count so far is 20 people it's just
that's crazy so horrible that's got to
be the highest priced real estate like
in almost the world yeah that area by
the way I don't live you live down you
live on the hillside like more in
downtown so yeah we're down exactly
we're more downtown so but we have
friends who live in Montecito who've
lost their homes and who have five feet
of mud and their houses and it just got
real and it's because the fire which was
the biggest fire the Thomas fire the
biggest fire in California history
happened in December we we never had
fires in December you know that what if
fire season is the summertime and so to
have a December fire to have that kind
of heat and dry and wind in December and
have a fire like that and then coming
close on the heels with all that rain
right it's it was just total it's all
just perfect stop so ready yeah slide
down the hill yeah it's so crazy and
your friend
Oprah like basically opened up her home
to become like this staging area right
that's Oprah does homey Oprah she died
you know and Ellen is up there and it's
rude they've been so hospitable to the
first responders you know everybody's
just the whole town is just come out
with open arms and open hearts and how
to help but it's just it's stunning you
you really you don't get it until you
see it I mean they're they're talking
about cholera you know because there's
so much raw sewage and rotting bodies
you know there are animals that you
forget that there are animal casualties
as well and so all of this is
sort of rotting and decaying in the mud
and poses a real continuing threat it's
like a crazy third-world problem yeah in
Montecito and you know I know but you
know it doesn't it appear that things
that were never possible before are
happening more and more I would say
that's an understatement yeah I know the
floods you know you you hear from a real
estate agent oh and I don't worry about
that he'll you know it would it would
take a 500 year flood to really a person
with that yeah and it's like those five
hundred year floods those hundred year
fires they're happening sort of on a
yearly basis now and the chickens are
coming home to roost as it were well
it's crazy times you know I always you
know there's that that kind of running
joke on Twitter where somebody will say
remember that thing you know and cite
some insane event that occurred and
current events and say yeah that was
earlier this week you know because we
just like crazy stuff happens we move on
the new cycle moves on and then we're on
to the next you know banana event we
don't have time to digest it I remember
I was in a crazy relationship it's just
like insane relationship many many many
years ago and I remember her while I was
in it thinking I don't even have time to
digest what's going on on a daily basis
because it's just such a shock to my my
you know my soul my heart and it takes
years to just digest one of these events
and like you said now in current events
that what's happening topically it's
like day after day after day you just
like you can't digest it all I know the
acceleration of it it's just yeah we're
not we're not wired for that
I don't think hmm you know no we're not
and yet here it is we have two wires
showing no signs of slowing down you
know I mean I just I tweeted the other
day like remember that whole UFO thing
remember right shouldn't we be talking
about that a little bit more major than
any other time we'd be like hold on like
you got the presses
right now pilots saw what they believed
to be a UFO these guys have like
nineteen years of flying
experience hey we're just like okay well
that was yesterday no because something
more serious and more insane like
nuclear war I don't know comes up you
know yeah I know I know
alright well we have the vegan ax steer
the original vegan s so we're going to
talk about that kind of stuff I love the
new book it's great I think it's timely
and it kind of hits the way I thought of
it is it really canvases like all the
major issues it's almost like this
synthesis of a lot of the works that are
currently out there including I had Paul
Shapiro in here a couple weeks ago you
know his book has a lot of similarities
to your book lean protein but you also
hit on the issues that Garth hits on and
protein holic and you cover the
environmental concerns of cowspiracy and
health concerns of how not to die in the
works of Neal Barnard and what the
health and you kind of compartmentalize
it and take it you know put it all
together in this one book that's very
digestible easy to read and and provide
you with you know a really practical
easy-to-follow roadmap for making these
changes in your own life that will
improve your health and and you know are
in the best interest of our planet and
large thank you that's a great summary
thank you very much how is the book tour
been the book tour has been great I mean
it's a fun thing to talk about protein
because it's a national obsession you
know so as soon as someone knows you've
written about protein they have a bunch
of questions they have a bunch of
comments or stories of what they have
been through and you know when they
shift and and so this is really this is
kind of a it's a buzzy conversation that
is I think timely but what with clean
meat and with you know just all the
different kind of alternative meats and
just with the Blue Zones stuff so
there's so many different kinds of
proteins and so many questions around it
so it's been a really fun experience so
let's define clean protein yeah
what is clean protein so protein comes
in a package it's like Harvard calls
that a protein package so you want to
think about what comes in
with that protein there's lots of things
that have protein yes chicken has a lot
of protein fish has a lot of protein
beef has a lot of protein but what comes
along with it is you want to ask
yourself is there cholesterol that comes
along with this protein is there a lot
of saturated fat are there drug residues
are there pathogens like e.coli
Salmonella is the protein inflammatory
to my body and what does the raising and
processing of this protein do to the
land and to the water and to climate
change so these are all questions that
we address in the book and we talk about
moving toward clean protein in a lot of
the ways that people have moved toward
clean energy you know as a culture we're
pivoting toward clean energy because of
a bunch of problems land degradation and
climate change all that stuff that comes
along with energy oil gas things like
that so in the energy sector we're
moving hopefully more and more toward
wind and solar and in protein is the
same thing if we want to sustain our
life on Earth we have to pivot away from
the way we are producing protein now
toward a cleaner way I couldn't agree
with you more
the protein obsession thing is quite
something
it's certainly real and it's kind of
interesting how you track like where
this all comes from like how did we
become so obsessed with protein and what
is that all about but before and I want
to hear about that before we even get
into that though I think it's sort of
important to even talk about what
protein is you know our mutual friend
Ray Cronus who you talked about in the
book you know he said he sort of
famously said like I wish that I wish
that word didn't even exist because it
causes so much confusion certainly
protein is a important macronutrient we
need it to live it's important for a
million different reasons but it creates
so much confusion because it's such a
loaded term so when we're talking about
protein we're really talking about an
assemblage of amino acids right 20 amino
has
nine of which the essential amino acids
are our amino acids that our bodies
cannot synthesize on their own and and
thus we must get from our food but
instead of talking about protein we
should be talking about like how are we
getting all of these amino acids right I
mean how do you think about it and talk
about it well we talk about it you know
I think people are worried oh my god I'm
not going to get a complete protein if
I'm just eating beans or if I'm just
eating and I explain what a complete
protein a complete protein is having all
those amino acids so your body needs all
those amino acids you know to function
properly but the good news is everything
in the vegetable kingdom
you know beans grains vegetables those
amino acids are everywhere scattered
throughout all the foods that grow in
the ground or on trees maybe not all of
them in every single food but if you are
eating things a diverse diet over the
course of a day a few days even a week
you're having you know oatmeal for
breakfast you're having a you know
lentil soup for lunch you're getting all
the amino acids you need so I think a
lot of people are really concerned that
they're not going to get a complete
protein and they have to be very careful
about food combining and that myth has
been debunked you don't really have to
worry about that right that idea that
that animal protein well let's talk
about this a little bit more in depth
the idea that animal protein is a
superior protein for for many reasons
one of which being that it is complete
and protein derived from plants
vegetable protein is inferior a because
it's incomplete and also there's this
sense or idea that how we digest these
proteins and and then assemble them or
put them to use in our bodies is somehow
different based upon the source mm-hmm
so what did you learn in your
exploration into this world of protein
that's subject yeah they're like for
instance beans are harder you know
you're not going to get you're not going
to be able to use readily use the
protein as much and if you soak them or
sprout them it's more available
yeah the bioavailability
is better when you sprout or soak them
but a you get everything that you need
and and as an athlete you must know it's
like you you eat a ton of food it's like
you eat giant plates of you know hearty
whole grains and beans and vegetables
and things like that so you're you're
getting a lot of it and your body ends
up getting what it needs mmm it's just
like the air you breathe you don't have
to worry about how am I gonna get the
correct oxygen you know you breathe if
you're athletic or if you're very active
you're you're breathing deeply you're
you know you're gonna take in as much as
you need your body does that right
that's certainly been my experience you
know as somebody who's been eating this
way for over 10 years at this point like
the idea of building lean muscle mass of
you know my body repairing itself in an
expedited manner to you know train as
hard as I train it's just it's just
never been an issue yeah you know and I
think there's this myth and this idea
that you know if you're an athlete you
need more and and and that more is
better
you know the recommended daily allowance
as you point out in the book is about
0.8 0.8 grams per kilogram of body
weight right so in my case that balance
is out to about I don't know somewhere
but you like around 70 75 grams of
protein a day and I don't really count
mm-hmm but when I do pay attention to
those sorts of things I probably come in
below that mm-hmm
yeah and I've read that the world health
organization actually estimates it much
lower much lower yeah I think they're
being cautious and there's they met and
they're kind of bowing to you know some
some concerns that people have but no
you really don't need as much as you
think you need on average probably you
know 48 grams for women 52 54 grams for
men but depending on how athletic you
are how active you are you easily get
that without even trying you easily get
that kind of protein so is there any
studies or indication that you need more
I think if you're a pregnant woman you
probably need a little bit more what
about for kids a lot of people who are
interested in adopting a plant-based
diet or going plant-based like they
worry
about their growing children yeah and I
understand that like I'm sympathetic to
that you know it's easy to just kind of
do what everyone there's there's comfort
in numbers right so it's just like well
that seems risky you know everyone else
is doing it this way it you know just to
be safe like I'm gonna mmm I'm gonna
make sure that they have eggs or or
whatever because I don't want to step
outside that paradigm and then if
something goes wrong I'm the one who's
you know to blame for that
yeah and I can understand that fear so
you know I know that I know zillion kids
who have been raised the vegan
plant-based since day one and they're
all thriving and fine so I understand
the mythical aspect of that but I'm
sympathetic to the concern of that for
sure for sure and that's what you want
to talk to a doctor who's up on all the
studies and who you know is not against
this this way of eating but the like dr.
Spock in his seventh edition and talked
about I know he's not but he but that
was the the final edition that he gave
his approval to and he said it's so
healthy for kids to eat a purely
plant-based diet and certainly joel
Fuhrman talks about this dr. joel
Fuhrman and know the research said even
the dietary guidelines which is so you
know tilted toward the industry and meat
and everything even they said pregnant
women nursing mothers children of all
ages it's totally fine to be plant-based
and by the way the book isn't really a
book about veganism or being plant-based
or anything like that it's really
dissecting you know what kinds of issues
come along with proteins so that's not
that the reader can make their own
decision about what kind of protein they
want to opt for obviously we we end up
in the place that plant protein is is
healthier you know not only for you but
for the for the land the water the
climate everything but but yeah it's
it's I think that the paradigm has to
shift I think when we look at how we're
raising our kids now kids are more
overweight and even obese than ever
childhood kids are getting type 2
diabetes it's insane it used to be
called adult onset diabetes you know and
now it's like kids are getting diabetes
at a very young age
and that is just it's wrought with so
many problems you know that go along
with that and so I think it's time to
change the paradigm I think it's a it's
great like do we want to keep raising
our kids the way they have historically
been raised so that they get addicted to
this fatty tastes this very rich flavor
of dairy and meat and stuff like that I
think it's a good thing that we're
shaking things up well we have to you
know we're facing this insane you know
obesity crisis like you said heart
disease rates are through the roof one
out of every three people dies of our
disease diabetes by 2050 something like
30% of Americans will be diabetic or
pre-diabetic type 2 it's these are the
epidemics of our time you know it's it's
absolute insanity and it's the food no
when we look at the food you know the
biggest culprits we have you know the
animal products we have the processed
foods we have the sugary foods all of
that it's all bad and we need to
innovate ways of creating healthy foods
that are palatable for people and are
also kinder on you know on our planet
and it's precious dwindling resources so
if you've seen conspiracy like you
understand what goes into generating
these foods that were obsessed with and
I would go so far as to say addicted -
it's just not sustainable
by any stretch of the imagination and
grass-fed is not going to cut it in
terms of saving the planet we need it
and we need a new way forward and the
way forward is right in front of our
faces it's eating plant-based and it is
the for those that aren't ready to make
that leap it is the innovations that
we're seeing in this cultured meat world
that is rapidly descending upon us and
very interesting and it's so exciting to
see these new innovations you know the
with clean meat growing meat for cells
from you know so it's real animal flesh
and sort of like what will be a brewery
kind of a thing but also the meat
alternatives and I'm a big fan of that
I'm not a purist and I know a lot of
people who are into super healthy ways
of eating are kind of anti veggie burger
sausage meat crumbles stuff like that
I'm a fan because they are far cleaner
than the animal-based versions of the
burger or sausage or chicken patty so
even though it's not as healthy as a
bowl of rice and beans and kale you're
having sausage that has no cholesterol
that has very little saturated fat that
has no Salmonella or ecoli or drug
residues it does not cause environmental
havoc and it didn't cause any suffering
so and they're getting better at making
them taste good they're so good oh my
god the beyond burger is beyond yeah I
mean and I enjoy these things from time
to time like I'm I am one of those more
purist people you're a super athlete I
mean but I but I recognize their
importance and I think that they have a
rare you know in a very you know strong
legitimate ya place in this discussion
because I don't know what are this -
maybe I mean isn't that you know it's
got to be really small and I think you
know this idea that we're all gonna be
struck vegan out of the generosity of
our hearts or you know even in the
interest of our own personal health is
just a it's a pipe dream and I wish that
that would happen and and I advocate for
people to think along those lines but I
also recognize the reality of the world
of Rin and the ticking clock you know
it's like we need we don't have enough
time now to wage that war we need to be
able to provide people with super tasty
alternatives that are more
environmentally sustainable better for
our health and yeah and and the like and
they have to taste just as good if not
better than it's available or the war is
lost that's right and I think it was
Victor Hugo who said
perfection is the enemy of the good and
I think a lot of people are
perfectionist they want to be super you
know healthy and and pure and that's
just asking a lot for a lot of people
who are just not interested in that you
know I'm from a small town in Georgia
Doraville Georgia and you know like that
I think it's Atlanta rhythm section that
song doraville no not a lot of vegans
there it's still not a lot of vegans
there and so I went down and picked up
my mom in Florida she lives outside of
Daytona and we drove up to Atlanta so
it's about a seven hour drive and so I
really got a reminder you know of how
hard it is to eat healthy in a lot of
the country in a lot of the world you
know we're lucky because we live in a
big city and there's lots of options and
we're around people who are curious and
entrepreneurs who are providing and
everything but in a lot of places they
have McDonald's and Denny's and Taco
Bell and that's it pretty much it yeah
and then there they're doing their
grocery shopping so I'm all for you know
Kroger's carrying a veggie burgers and
veggie sausage and you know going Taco
Bell for being taco you know we we have
to look for the better you know and not
hold out for perfection and encourage
people to just sort of lean forward
yeah and Walmart and Costco are the two
biggest organic retailers in the world I
don't know in America that's I mean you
know them together and so I think I
agree with that I think you know a
couple observations first we need to
celebrate the small victories within the
system I think the idea that you want to
you're gonna be this you know punk
rocker who's gonna just you know want to
blow up the system and anybody who has
anything to do with McDonald's is an
evil person it's like you got to disrupt
from within yeah I know I've often said
like if the McDonald's ought ask me to
come and speak
I would do that in a second place you
need to get these people to understand
what the future is about and that's in
their best interest to like get on board
with this plant-based movement because
that's where we're headed
yeah and that and it makes it makes
economic capitalist sense for them to do
so because this is the shifting appetite
of the Millennials as they grow like you
know young people they don't they have a
whole different view on this whole thing
like they're far more of a halt than our
generation well you know we're attached
to our ways I think that's a natural
thing that we we grew up with certain
foods and we are you know we're attached
to the way we think and Millennials
they're in Generation Z I mean they're
there they're kind of seeing climate
change they're they're seeing their
parents getting sick or their
grandparents getting sick so yeah
they're class meeting yeah that's right
that's right you know and they're seeing
theirs they're also they've been raised
on the internet and and they have an
inherent expectation of transparency
that that we weren't really raised on
like wait you mean like we can't see
like how that was made and they're not
gonna tell us like that doesn't sound
right yeah you know where's us it's just
like well that's the way yeah you know
what I mean and I think on this other
point of view you know kind of going
back to your hometown is this idea of
you know you're getting outside your
bubble right and and as much as I like
to think that I'm a broad thinker and
and I'm not just you know sort of in my
bubble and I'm thinking about what the
average person you know has to contend
with yeah we're in a huge bubble here
you know and it's funny like when I go
outside it and I'm like oh yeah like
wait people still do that they still eat
that way it's like oh yeah like I have
to be reminded in an airport I see the
line at McDonald's versus you know the
line it at well in the American Airlines
terminal at LAX they have the real food
daily yeah nobody's in line there
McDonald's or whatever I'm like getting
one of everything my flight just because
except it's so deactive yeah I would get
a burrito there and like one other thing
and it was like $40
no no seriously yeah it was it was crazy
I think the bottled water that I got
with it was like nine dollars but that's
just the airport I know it's the airport
yeah but that's not helping what
McDonald's is so artificially cheap I
mean and it's just such a hit on the
taste buds that we'll just love it you
know and well I think I think that you
know on this issue of the bubble you
know that's why I feel so strongly about
doing this podcast and trying to put the
best show out there because it's able to
reach people who live in places like
that small town you know and and don't
have access to these kinds of ideas or
it's just not part of the daily
conversation yeah and there they get to
participate in that and and kind of
expand their horizons by virtue of what
the Internet has to offer and feel like
they're part of a community I think
that's the great thing that you've
created as you've created a community I
mean everywhere I go people say oh yeah
I heard you on the ritual podcast it's
like forget about I saw you on Ellen but
I heard you on the ritual podcast you've
got this great community of people who
feel like they're not alone they're not
isolated they are with and among other
people who are wanting to grow wanting
to expand their circle of care and
concern they want to do better for their
bodies they're there creating the
conversation so you kick off all these
conversations in you know first this
online community this podcast community
you've got but then people take it back
into their families they talk to their
friends about it and it makes it it's a
ripple effect it's really true you know
you're you're dropping the stone in the
pond and it's rippling out there is that
little studio it's funny because I don't
I mean I get that when I travel and I
interact with people yeah I get outside
of LA but you know I'm just here doing
my thing and I see that numbers and I'm
like oh wow a lot of people are
listening to this but that's just an
abstract concept you know until I
actually go out I'd travel somewhere to
give a talk and then I get to actually
meet people and it's
meaningful yeah it's meaningful to me
personally and it just it's so great
that you know it's able to have that
kind of impact on a huge impact huge and
I think so much of it is that people
don't want to feel socially isolated
you know this appeals to them and it
strikes you know some sort of
recognition like this is right and I'm
not crazy I'm not a weirdo I'm not like
a radical person who's you know a an
ideologue or whatever I have all these
other people who are thinking like me
who have curiosity like me who want to
do more for my body want to do more for
the planet like I actually really care
and by the way I'm not a tree-hugging
animal loving no you're not a hippie guy
I'm not a hippie I mean I I lived in
Woodstock did you do it I used to live
in Woodstock so I'm I've got the hippie
in me a teeny tiny bit but when I moved
to California I had a girlfriend ammonia
pee well I had this friend she walked
into my closet I had an apartment and
she said show me your shoes
and I had three pairs of shoes I had a
pair of Doc Martens and a pair of
Birkenstocks and like a pair of I don't
know some kind of little black dator so
this must have been a very long time ago
I am taking you shopping these shoes
I've got to go you live in LA now and I
was like but I'm comfortable they're so
comfortable and and that's what we wore
Woodstock never I never thought about it
but um yeah I had to change up my game a
little bit I have a hard time seeing
that that's not part of the picture the
mental image I will show you picture
your life rich you guys come over one
night all about the photo albums and you
will see I I was a bonafide hippie
mm-hmm I'm good at adapting so on this
subject of protein the number one
question obviously for anybody is you
know where you get your protein oh
you're gonna go plant-based your
interview where you gonna get your
protein you can't get your protein right
and and kind of baked into that is this
idea that plants don't have protein that
you know you're gonna somehow wither and
die and what I'm interested in is what
you found out in the process of writing
this book about how we got to this place
where that myth became the predominant
sort of conventional wisdom about food
because it didn't just happen out of the
blue like there are vested interests
that yeah you know benefit from us
believing this yeah well you hit the
nail on the head it's vested interest I
mean there's an industry that is
producing a product and in order to sell
that product they have to sell a story
and the story is that you need this
product and that product is animal
protein its animal foods so there's a
whole industry that markets this product
called animal food and it there's a
checkoff program where they take you
know maybe five dollars off the head of
every animal every cow that's sold and
they have to plow that back into the
marketing of this product and that's
that's like a government program you you
it's mandated you have to do that as a
producer so and to put a pin in that
just for a quick moment yeah when I had
Neal Barnard on the on the podcast he
told the story just to kind of
illustrate the checkoff program that
that's why you see these ads for like I
don't know if this is specifically
correct but like Pizza Hut with the
cheese in the crust
you know the Taco Bell burritos that has
the super duper extra cheese or whatever
it's because there are actually
government checkoff dollars that are
being funneled towards these advertising
agencies and these corporations to
market these food products so the
government is actually in bed with the
fast food industry the animal
agriculture industry to push these
products and there's no uncertain terms
about it and that makes you just kind of
wake up and say wow there's no one
really advocating for me you know it's
not the government they're not
advocating for me I have to advocate for
myself I have to dig and figure out what
is right what what seems right and
that's another thing they do is they
fund quote unquote
you know studies so that the studies
show what they wanted to show and I'm
sure you know you you've seen like
studies you can make it come out a lot
of different ways depending on how you
sort of structure structure it and you
know talk about it and so so that the
results get so confusing so the person
who wants to understand about how much
protein they need or what you know what
they're missing or is it safe or
whatever there's a lot of shoddy science
out there but there's also a lot of
half-right science and that's the most
confusing is when there's a kernel of
truth and so you say oh yeah that's true
I know that to be true cuz I read that
somewhere else but then the rest of it
is kind of wonky so it's just enough to
muddy the waters and confuse the
consumer so that the consumer says ah
moderation it's also confusing one week
they tell you one thing another week
they tell you something else I'm
watching these you know medical shows
I'm reading all this stuff and it's just
so confusing so moderation I'm just
gonna eat the way that I grew up eating
and that's a slippery slope because
moderation means different things to
different people and you know certain
kind of foods are addictive mmm-hmm I
wonder if somebody in if somebody in
like 1974 who was like going vegan you
know making that radical leap because
that would be kind of radical back then
if the response would be where do you
get your protein like I don't know that
that would be the reaction mm-hmm
because the culture was different that's
right they might have thought like oh
you're gonna be malnourished or you're
gonna be weak but it wouldn't be where
are you gonna get your protein like
that's a newer concept and you know it's
interesting to kind of track back like
how we got to that isn't it brilliant
they did such a good job well I think
yes I mean I don't know this for a fact
and you certainly you and Bruce you know
we should mention oh really
- I'm gonna have on again who's you know
so eloquent and intelligent about all
these matters
yeah damn smart he you know I think my
sense is that this all kind of came
online in a big way with with the
explosion of like body bodybuilding
culture and Arnold Schwarzenegger and
when these bodybuilders in Venice Beach
started to try to gorge on protein and
they were the first ones to kind of take
to figure out what way was to go to
these cheese producers and get that
extract and like make these supplemental
right nutritional products out of what
was essentially being thrown out the way
by the dairy yeah it was the waste yeah
and using like these acids to extract
these curds to create this high you know
protein content food which at that time
tastes terrible yeah and then you would
see then there are these documentaries
and you see these huge guys and they're
they're doing these shakes and that kind
of created a whole industry when the
dairy industry realized all the stuff
we're throwing out like we can make
billions of dollars by reframing the
discussion around what this is and
convincing people that this is an elixir
of health and I think that was the birth
of like that was sort of the genesis of
how we started to walk this path towards
this obsession with protein and this
idea that more is better and that we
need you know more than we think we need
and only to wake up to now you go to the
grocery store and every food label has
emblazoned on the front of it and giant
you know bold font you know how many
grams of protein and product as in the
implicit message behind that is that you
need more right it's it is the
groupthink it is in the zeitgeist and
and I think that that's kind of where we
have to meet people because that is a
that is an obsession so some people have
said to me Kathy why are you even
talking about protein you just
underscore you know that it's that it's
a real thing that we should be thinking
about and it's not so people know and
that's a that's the thing that's what
people are talking about that's what
they want to know so I think we kind of
have to meet the discussion where it is
and respectfully address it you know
respectfully answer all those concerned
questions because it's a
I know when I was switching I was like
oh my god what am I gonna do for calcium
you know and am I gonna get enough iron
and where do I get my protein that I
wasn't trying to be obnoxious I was
really concerned because you know a
doctor had said something to me my
mother was very concerned friends were
sort of lecturing me about you know the
mistake that I was making so I was
asking these questions in earnest and I
think that it's tempting to sort of
laugh it off with a joke and you know
say oh I eat children you know to get my
protein and but it's it's not it's not
funny to people it's not and it's not
helpful I mean it's a real concern and
and there's also I think there's like
what's the word it's not a placebo but
if someone is moving away from animal
protein and they're not eating well if
they're tired or they're they they're
sick or they're they're gonna blame it
on protein it'll be the first thing
they're gonna yeah so I think it's
actually really important that we talk
about this and we talk about it a lot
because there's a lot to counter there's
a lot of so when someone asks you where
do you get your protein what do you say
what is your worst do you have a canned
response or do you take that on a
case-by-case basis depending on who
you're talking to depending on who I'm
talking to but the truth is it's pretty
much always the truth and I'm a big
beans fan you know I am My partner is
stand Buettner of he's the founder of
Blue Zones which is a study of
populations around the world where
people live the longest and are the
healthiest and so everybody listening
knows who Janna's loves praises he's so
brilliant and so I'm with like dreaming
he is dreamy and you know what the best
part about him is is that he makes the
best damn beans you've ever had in your
life this man has recipes from all over
the world on how to make beans taste
good so and he says that the single best
thing you can do for your health and law
end to promote longevity is to add in at
least a cup of beans a day
so I'm a big fan of beans you know
lentils one cup of lentils which is like
a an inch basically and I'm in a
measuring cup has 18 grams of protein
and one egg only has six grams of
protein and most people eat eggs because
they're thinking oh I need my protein
but there's not a lot of protein there
there's roughly half as in the yolk and
half as in the in the white but so with
one cup of lentils you're getting 18
grams plus you're getting tons of
healthy fiber and iron and antioxidants
and and you're feeling full because of
all the fiber and you're not getting all
that cholesterol so it's just a matter
of you know talking about where we get
our protein so I that's my favorite I I
eat hummus for snack you know at the end
of the day dan is big on wine at five or
six whatever and we have a little hummus
and crackers and I have you know lentil
soup and crusty bread for lunch or you
know black bean burger or whatever I
just I just love being that's my
favorite source of protein yeah well
that's a great response and it sounds
delicious
yes exactly
my favorite but the kind of truth behind
it is that it's it is a red herring
because if you're just eating if you're
eat it like okay let's presume you're
not eat just eating processed crap but
if you're just eating like random plant
foods throughout the day mindlessly
without even really paying attention and
a couple bananas some whatever like it's
a non-issue you will meet your protein
needs you will get all those amino acids
that you're worried about will be taken
care of Yeah right
so the real thing and you talked about
this in the book and I've said it many
times before the thing that we need to
be sort of focused on or we need to kind
of shift this discussion towards and it
is away from this issue of protein and
onto fiber because people are not
protein deficient they're eating too
much protein they're probably eating two
to three times as much protein as the
need and those are the sedentary people
but I don't know what the percentage is
maybe you know most people are fiber
deficient if they're not eating any
fiber 90 percent of Americans do not get
enough vitamin D yeah so and and fiber
that's the question we should be asking
each other not where are you getting
your protein but where are you getting
your fiber are you getting enough fiber
what are you what are your thing we
should be asking each other is you know
where how are you sure you're getting
enough fiber because fiber is like this
miracle component of food and it acts
like a scrub brush as you know going
through the body cleaning out all the
gunk and toxicity and it keeps you
feeling full so you're not overeating
with other foods and it disperses the
blood sugar the glucose throughout the
day very steadily and slowly and so your
blood sugar is good and it's associated
with lower incidences of heart disease
and type 2 diabetes and cancer all kinds
of things so the fact that most
Americans aren't getting enough fiber
that's a real problem and interestingly
plant foods all plant foods have fiber
lots of fiber fibers like bones are two
animals humans like our bones you know
hold everything together so fiber is
like a plants bones and so everything in
the plant kingdom has fiber and nothing
in the plant kingdom has cholesterol and
then if you look in the other column you
look at animal animal protein has zero
fiber zilch zero nada nothing and it has
lots of cholesterol and lots of
saturated fat so you look at these two
things and you think what's my protein
package on one side it's lots of fiber
none of the problems and on the other
side it's no fiber and a lot of you know
issues that come along with it so you
want to move away from the old sources
of protein which is animal and toward
clean protein which tends to be plain
bass mm-hmm and how do you talk about
organic versus non-organic you know
that's not the prime issue for me it's
not the prime issue for the book just
because a lot of people I don't always
have access to organic and you know it
certainly in parts of the country if
you're only you know seven eleven is
your your local grocery store and
Denny's and so you don't always have
access or you know you can't always
afford it but certainly if you can
afford it definitely and stay away from
the Dirty Dozen that you definitely
don't want to eat right the Dirty Dozen
is the environmental working groups
annual list of the plant foods that are
the ones you should definitely stay away
from in terms of being conventionally
grown versus organic like strawberries
man they they were hazmat suit you know
if those strawberries are not organic
it's like really toxic so if I'm out I
would not eat in organic strawberries I
would just opt opt out of them but I
don't worry too much about that stuff I
think it's an exciting time right now I
think we can agree that this plant-based
movement this vegan movement has finally
sort of reached that tipping point where
it's part of the mainstream discourse
and that's due in no small parts of
books like you've written and these
documentaries that are sort of being
released with you know increasing
frequency that have people talking about
these things but at the same time and
I've talked about this before on the
show there seems to be kind of a a war
for the hearts and minds of people right
now on on one side we have plant-based
people like yourself and many of the
doctors and nutritionists and dietitians
that have had on this program and
athletes etc and on the other side we
have this sort of ascendancy of the low
carb high fat / ketosis I don't know if
you can totally align those two they
have differing points of view in certain
points but that seems to be very popular
right now and I would imagine just
you know in your world and the circles
that you kind of you know navigate
through that you're you're you're
hanging out with certain people that are
on board with that right now so when
someone comes to you and says I lost all
this weight or I'm doing ketosis or I'm
all about that like how do you think
about that and well it breaks my heart
number one and number two I'm old enough
and hopefully wise enough to know that I
can never change anyone's mind and so if
someone is set on doing something or
eating a certain way it's not on me to
try to change them I think someone has
to be curious from their own place so it
is really unfortunate that this paleo
ketosis sort of thing is on the rise but
I get that people want to be fit and
they they read certain science and it
seems like it makes a lot of sense
certainly I have brothers that are on
that diet you know but I would say that
wellness and well-being and health is
not a singular sector of the pie which
is our individual health that's part of
it but it's also the planet it's also
the climate it's also our land and our
water and our trees and our our Natural
Preserve so you want to look at your
diet your choices and determine how does
that not only affect me my body so I can
understand you know maybe for whatever
reason you think that this is better for
your body let's look at it and and see
how it does for the environment is that
you let's look at animal agriculture if
that's if that's really what you want to
eat let's look at see what it does and
the science is pretty clear on that that
the like there's a report called
livestock's long shadow done undertaken
by the United Nations and they
determined that livestock causes 18% of
all global warming gases
and it causes land degradation and sucks
up all this water usage and creates
these cesspools of problems that go out
into the our food system and chops down
rainforests so that you know grazing for
cattle which then releases all that
climate change gases it was revised just
to say I think it caused 15% rather than
18% but the World Bank says it caused
51% of all climate change gases so that
those are serious numbers so that means
that it causes more problem for the
climate than all the transportation
sources put together all the trucks and
cars and planes and everything so you
want to say okay let's look at something
that's good for my body that's good for
the land the water the climate and not
to be too precious but like let's honor
these other creatures on the planet
these animals you know again I did not
grow up to be a touchy-feely tree
hugging animal lover it's not like I
popped out of the womb that way but once
you see how animals are treated even in
the best of circumstances they cling to
life they do not want to die to have
bonds with their families and it's it's
just kind of disturbing it's a shock to
the conscience what's happening on a
vast scale and as countries get
wealthier like China and India and
they're seeking to eat like we eat more
protein then it's it's pretty shocking
what's happening so we want to consider
the whole picture a holistic idea of
health and interestingly enough
plant-based sort of hits all checks all
those boxes it definitely does I'm
interested in your level of optimism
about people's inherent altruism you
know what I mean because I think there
are certain people when they see the
environmental implications of this
they're like oh my god this is you know
I cannot abide you know I'm in and other
people are like I just you know I'm just
trying to pay the bills man yeah like
you know whatever like I can't be
concerned with it yeah well your
listeners
the former your you know your community
is people who are thinking about it who
are altruistic to at least some extent
probably a lot and who are very
progressive citizens of this planet but
that's why I'm a big fan of alternative
meets and like let's have McDonald's
have a veggie burger let's do that let's
get clean me past and let's let's not
fight against this stuff because that's
progress and a lot of people definitely
just want something that tastes good and
it's affordable it's available and
that's it I know a lot of people like
that myself that's not going to change
so let's get those things out there all
those entrepreneurs who are out there
working on things let's support them
let's make it let's let's lift them up
and and not be so purist and you know
perfectionist that we all have to eat
you know absolutely perfectly organic
and and things that grow in the ground
or on trees absolutely yeah you know I I
am shocked at my own evolution with this
because I I watched a video that I
thought I did like this was this was
like a maybe two years into being
plant-based and PETA came to my house
and Lisa Lisa lounge interviewed me for
for a little video that they did and at
that time I was still somebody who like
my life had been changed dramatically by
eating a plant-based diet like
180-degree difference revolutionized you
know how I felt how my body performed
but I was still very much of the mind
that this was just about me and my
personal health and I was starting to
sense you know the power of advocating
for this lifestyle on behalf of other
people taking greater control of their
own personal health but the idea that
that you know these that these decisions
had environmental implications and that
there were ethical considerations to be
thought about it was just not part of I
wasn't comfortable going there yeah that
wasn't like my thing and now like that's
a huge part of how I see all of it but
wasn't ready to hear that then even
after being a couple years into it right
so I'm sensitive to people who are
standing on the outside of it and how
easily that door can get shut because
people don't preach do that and want to
hear about it you know on the one hand
it's like hey man you got to go on your
own journey like let's support you on
your journey and then you have to
balance that against this ticking clock
that we're on like we you know we're
like the mud slot like everything that's
going on right now there's a there's a
sense of urgency yeah as well yeah so I
don't know where I'm heading we are
we're kind of at a fork in the road and
no pun intended but there's you know we
can definitely keep as a culture going
the way that we're going and stay
obsessed with protein and the climate
keeps amping up and you know we keep
getting angrier and we keep getting
fatter and sicker and it can go that way
and I don't know how things turn out or
we can go down another road and we
talked about this in the book that you
know if enough activists food activists
wellness activists really get in there
that and empower entrepreneurs and
support businesses and you know talk
about this stuff and change the way
schools are serving lunches to kids and
we go and we talk to our employers and
ask for more options the we can change
the culture I mean that's the way that's
the way things happen but it's kind of
in our hands it's it's literally in our
hands it's a fork well yeah there's no
there's no conspiracy to repress us I
think the market just responds to demand
and we have to shift demand yeah you
know that that begins with our own
personal choices and then how we kind of
carry ourselves yeah in the world but
you know I think we can all agree when
we look at factory farming that it's an
abomination and the way these animals
are treated is just abhorrent like it's
just it's just there's no ethical
argument to be had it's just it's
terrible across the board in every way
shape or form and when you look at the
dairy industry you know it was it was
news to me I had to learn that later
like how bad that
is and how awful they treat these
animals like nobody we're all inherently
compassionate people and I think once
you are exposed to that and you see it
you realize that you know that our
actions have an impact on whether we
perpetrate that system or we overcome it
and there's a numbness that is required
you know to keep your eyes shut to that
and your awareness away from that
because it's you know twenty years ago
maybe you wouldn't really know how
animals are treated but now it's so we
all have computers we can all see stuff
we've seen things on the news you know
so there's a numbness a shutdown
unconsciousness that is required to not
feel this stuff and that numbness goes
across in every sector of our lives so
how how fully are we living in any
sector of our lives if we're shut down
in one area I think it creates a
dissonance you know you if you have some
awareness however conscious or
unconscious that awareness is and then
to act in in contradiction to that
awareness creates like a an unhealthy
dissonance in your body and in your mind
and in your spirit and that's like a
low-grade like unhealthy thing to walk
around with yeah it sounds weird I mean
it's kind of like a it's kind of like a
spiritual malady it is but when you
develop that awareness and you align
your actions with that more
compassionate value that I think we all
have inherently you know as part of who
we are as human beings there's kind of a
lightness and a freedom that comes with
that
and that's definitely been my experience
but I think what I think the most common
occurrence is the person who the
well-intentioned person who's like okay
Cathy I hear you like I get it like I'm
gonna try and then they try and life
gets busy and they fall off the wagon
and they and then they beat themselves
up because they know like I just like
you know I don't like the way those
animals are treated or I know what it's
doing to the planet and I don't feel
good but like it's just too hard or the
social you know kind of I think it's the
social structures that that make it
difficult
people like I'm going out to dinner with
my friends or I'm going to a party or
I'm going to whatever like they don't
want to stick out like a sore thumb they
don't know how to navigate the social
landmines that are part and parcel of
trying to do something a little bit
different than their peers and that's
again we talk about in the book so you
know how do you speak to that or try to
help people figure out a strategy that
allows them to you know adhere to this
commitment that they've made to
themselves without the becoming like a
social pariah yeah well my my favorite
way of approaching anything is to lean
into it and to just give yourself the
space and time to just find your way
don't lean forever don't take forever to
lean but lean into it so that you find
your way so you're not going to show up
to a dinner or a holiday and starve you
know you want to you want to just give
yourself some time to figure things out
like how do I prepare we've got a lot of
tips and tricks and in the book and how
to you know have a snack before you go
out if you don't think your relatives
are gonna have anything or how to stop
by the grocery store bring some
leftovers so that you can bring
something to a dinner party or a holiday
so you you feel like you're you're part
of everything but I think you really hit
on something that's very important and
that is social isolation you don't want
to stick out like a pariah you you kind
of want to be part of the community
actually I you know I I grew up very
attached to my traditions and my you
know friends and community and stuff
like that but once I started learning
about it I was super excited I didn't
really care I was very happy to be an
oddball and actually kind of proud of it
I'm like oh my god I love that I'm in on
this early you know and it's still early
I mean to be in on this now you're still
early but and I know you know people who
have lost
of resources and they still felt like
they were isolated so I think it's
really important to get your community
happening and I think that's what you're
doing that's what Dan is doing with Blue
Zones I think it's what we do on
Instagram and Facebook and so you see
that there's there are a whole lot of
people who think this way who want to
make it happen so that you don't feel
like you're an oddball you know you
definitely are out front you're on the
front curve of this movement but you're
still part of a community and you're not
alone and then once you see all the
great food and you start entertaining
and you have friends over I would say
fully 75% of my friends are meat-eaters
but when they come to my house they have
great food and they always return saying
you know what I can do this I can eat
less less meat and little that's how
change happens because we normalize it
you know people who are eating this way
we normalize it that's why I'm I'm I
kind of believe in the 2% rule like if
there's 2% of anything just let it go
don't be annoying you know if you're in
a restaurant you don't want to quiz the
waiter are you sure are you absolutely
sure there's no egg in this bread you
know it's like you're not doing any
favor to anyone you're just making the
whole plant-based things seem stringent
and annoying annoying yeah so like go
with it do the best that you can and
serve great food and and once you find
some people to follow on Instagram and
and Facebook that they're we're posting
great pictures of recipes I know you
guys have amazing cheese is at your
house and I love coming to your house
and I'm sure if people come to your
house and have cheese and crackers
they're like oh my god I can still have
my cheese and crackers I didn't realize
that yeah they're like I'm a they're
like what there's no dare they can't
believe it
you know they can't believe it but in
fairness like everyone knows now like
everyone knows when they go to your
house yeah you know they're gonna have a
plant-based meal similarly at our house
I think somebody who's just beginning
I sort of analogize it to when you're
newly sober you're like oh my god I have
to go
wedding in six months what am I gonna do
how am I gonna how am I going to go to a
wedding rehearsal over a bachelor party
whatever like whatever it is right yeah
you future trip yeah and you're like
that's impossible I can't do it so you
don't you either don't begin or you just
get so caught up in this future event
that hasn't even occurred they don't
talk yourself out of what you're capable
of and I think it's very similar with
this like how am I going to go home for
Thanksgiving or or or wedding or we
don't you know whatever it is like
because they people really get
uncomfortable with having to be mm-hmm
that person who's sticking out yeah and
they don't want to make a fuss or yeah
or they just I don't know or they're
like I'm gonna starve or whatever
whatever it is yeah I just go and I
bring it's like for Thanksgiving I bring
some beyond meat or Gardein or something
like that and I pop it in the oven
wherever whose heifers if I'm going to
dance dance house or something like that
I'll just pop it in the oven and and I
always bring more I always bring more
than just for me and just for Dan
because inevitably people want to try it
and they love it they finally they fall
in love with it it happens every single
time I bring stuff and it's like people
will say oh wow I didn't realize it
tasted this good and then they're gonna
fold it in to their diets they're gonna
because that's a doorway the doorway is
tasting good feeling part of things and
if I can't tell you how many people say
if I knew I could eat this way I'd eat
it that way every day if I if things
tasted this good I'd eat that way every
day and guess what things can taste that
good every day so I think it also
involves some kind of social strategies
around how you talk about it and the
kind of love that you carry you know
with it into that environment because
especially if it's a family like it's
loaded right like your mom always made
this thing for Thanksgiving or Christmas
or Easter or whatever holiday or
whatever you're just going home and for
you to bring something else in can be
interpreted as a rejection of that
person like you don't love me you're
rejecting me because you're rejecting my
which seems insane but that's a very
real thing sure and so I think you need
to like have like strategies for
approaching that so that there's
communication like healthy communication
so that people aren't misinterpreting
those social cues as that rejection and
more about like I'm just doing this for
me or like downplaying it like hey I
just thought I'd what out you know like
being low-key about it or whatever I
think I think that we in any situation
you think what-what would feel good to
me like if someone were going to come to
my house like what would feel good to me
how would how would I talk to that and I
think that that's the way I talked to
other people so not judgmental just
really curious and just say oh my god I
love your green bean so much they're so
good I can't wait to pile on in that or
your apple pie or whatever it is and
just say you know this just this I'm
eatin plant-based these days I don't
want you to have to waste a piece of
fish or steak on me so I'm gonna bring
my own but I'll uh you know just be
complimentary and can't wait to see
totally and I tell you one thing I do
these days is I don't bring wine or
flowers anymore I always bring my
favorite plant-based food and
plant-based proteins because I think
that's like an exposure cuz me you know
I can't tell you how many people have
walked through the grocery store because
they they're like I don't know what to
get I mean so you bring them stuff like
this is what it looks like
you know these this is what the beyond
burgers look like this is what the field
Rose sauce is just looks like here's the
bag of lentils and a bunch of recipes
you know here's my favorite cookbook or
my favorite book so these are ways of
advocating in like a joyful way you know
you're not pushing it down anyone's
throat but when you go to dinner it's
like okay I cooked this up and here's
the recipe it came from this book in
case in case you like it you know that's
cool I like that let's talk about the
the clean meat stuff have you tried like
Memphis meats or any of these things
would you haven't but I sure would would
absolutely yeah I would definitely have
a meatball that's real meat if it was
clean meat and clean meat you know is
meat that is real animals
eles grown from the cells into real
animal flesh but no slaughter so it is
cruelty-free no environmental footprint
definitely not as healthy as lentils you
know I'm not saying it's healthy but
it's clean and so it's clean on the
conscience of course because the animals
aren't hurt and it's clean on the
environment so yeah I would definitely
have a meatball would you I don't know I
don't know I
you know Paul Shapiro tried it I mean
that guy's been like vegan vegetarian
forever right he's like but you know
he's ready to book about it he's gonna
try it you know ethical vegan vegetarian
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know it's a good question I'm sure
that eventualities will present itself I
would I would I mean not clearly like
we're not the market for that like yeah
I actually got freaked out by the
impossible burger like I don't taste it
so I don't like I don't really like it I
think it's great that it exists and I
think that it's an important product
yeah that'd be made available for people
but for me it just weirded me out you
know
yeah and so I can't imagine what really
you know I know B and I think you know
maybe just out of curiosity I would but
it's not like oh man that's going to be
my jam yeah there's no way yeah but man
it's a game changer
it is a game changer when when all these
food suppliers are you know putting in
hot pockets and they're supplying
schools and fast food places when that
it's like when you know electricity was
discovered or kerosene was discovered oh
we don't need whale oil anymore and
overnight whale oil became obsolete
that's what's gonna happen when this
clean meat gets up to speed there ain't
gonna be any need for animals and that's
gonna be a game changer my hope is that
we'll we'll look back on this era and
think you know how about barbaric was
that that we that we had this whole
system set up to raise these animals and
torture them and the impact that that
had on the planet and the environment
and you know it just didn't it doesn't
make sense yeah right when there's this
alternative
that is so much more environmentally
sustainable and clearly there's no there
there isn't well there is I guess there
is a I mean there's a there's a small
ethical quandary it's sort of like a
stem cell argument like okay well what
is this that we're eating there's
certainly an ick factor that we're gonna
have to get over so there's the bigger
Nick factor if you look at the
slaughterhouses yeah if you like people
are like oh that's great it's lab ground
like that's just weird me out and it's
gross but like all right well but you're
cool with like all the hormones and
these these animals that are like
walking around in their own fecal matter
totally and scalding and peeling off the
skin and cutting off the hooves and I
mean it's gnarly it's gross talk about
an ick factor all you have to do is
google factory-farmed meat and just look
at a slaughterhouse video and that is
like so full of ech you know so but
there's a real be an acclamation period
- yeah sure I mean like I have a hard
time imagining that I'm gonna sit in the
backseat of a car that's gonna drive
itself but clearly that's gonna is
happening exactly this is happening and
and you know the the clean meat can't
happen fast enough personally I'm not
gonna I don't think I would consume it
regularly at all I'm definitely gonna
taste it because I'm principled I want
to say hey I have no problem with this
at all but like you I've lost my taste
for me and I actually love the taste of
plant-based food and the simpler the
better I'm kind of I can kind of eat
like a peasant you know bowl of rice and
beans and some local vegetables and I'm
so happy it doesn't take much but then
every once in a while I need a burger
you know I need a hotdog we went to an
event last night and they had a one of
those food trucks outside of the event
that sometimes they serve burgers and
hotdogs and I was like oh damn cuz I've
got the munchies you know it's been a
long night and I want to have something
and lo and behold they had all these
veggie burgers and hotdogs and
everything and got to eat I'd got to dig
in just like everybody else and it felt
it felt a little wicked you know
certainly not healthy but it was fun
it's amazing how how many places have
the beyond burger no like you know
burger places all over the
like most places now have some kind of
veggie patty option yeah and that was
not the case even a couple years now
it's changed so much so fast the world
is definitely changing and and I think
we as food activists we have to embrace
that and empower people to try this
stuff feel good about it not shame them
because it's got a little oil in it or
you know it's a little bit processed or
whatever it's the better so we want to
fight for the better
mm-hmm let's talk about Bruce and GFI
yeah so good food Institute you're like
on the board of directors or advisors
I'm on the board of directors that the
good food Institute you don't go way
back with Bruce right Bruce and I have
been friends for gosh over a decade now
and he's always been someone I looked up
to so much he's so brilliant I mean
whenever I needed something like an
insight about something or fact Jack or
what do you think about this or what's
your opinion on this Bruce is sort of
the sage he kind of knows everything so
we were having dinner at Crossroads I
think a couple of years ago probably two
or three years ago and we were talking
about clean meat and what's coming and
protein and everything and I said you
know what Bruce you should write a book
called the future of protein and he said
that's a great idea why don't you do it
with me and I was like no I'm tired I
don't want to write heavy books I don't
want to write right now and you don't
need me just do this you guys well I'm
not gonna do it without you and I said
well how about I'll just work on a
proposal let's see how it comes out and
we sent it in to my agent and so that's
how we we wrote the book together but he
is he is just about the smartest
loveliest human being and the most
hard-working human being you've ever
seen in your life I mean I I I get
emails from him at all hours or he's
doing you know work and just empowering
people to help these entrepreneurs so
that they can create that's what good
food institute does actually thank you
let's talk about like what they're doing
and maybe like I had Bruce on it was a
year ago look
what's going on more recently with GFI
and what your involvement is yeah well
so they're they are going into
universities they're teaching clean meat
courses they're teaching clean protein
courses there and they're going into
food systems they're they're supporting
entrepreneurs it's sort of like
incubators really helping people
formulate their business plans get
funding get it out there so they're
they're all about moving the world
toward more sustainable protein they're
amazing and so what is your do you have
like a you don't have a daily like
involvement one yeah sort of like an
advisor time in a yeah I'm an advisor
yeah that's cool I'm just I'm just
excited to be part of it to tell you the
truth because there's no but no other
organization that's doing this and
they're all about science they're all
about food science they're they don't
they're not precious about anything it's
not an animal welfare organization and
which I love animal welfare
organizations they are hiring lobbyists
to support these companies so it's a
it's a kind of a game-changing
organization that I'm really proud to be
part of right and the big players right
now in this space are Hampton Creek or
they just rebranded their name Reiter
they they call just now did they change
the name yeah sure I think it's called
just yeah beyond meat obviously
impossible foods Memphis meats fantastic
yeah there's and tofurkey that's been
around for a while field roast that's
been around for a while the early
adaptors you know the gardening Gardein
yeah there's how many good ones so many
good ones in good people who really
really have a mission like they have a
Purpose Driven mission that they want to
make this world better they want to make
human health better in the environment
better so it's exciting to support them
what was the most surprising like you've
you've been
this for a long time like you've been
around the block in the vegan world but
in the process of writing this book was
there something you came across that
surprised you that you didn't know or
that you learned that you thought was
you didn't realize going into this
process of writing this book I didn't
realize how big of an issue protein was
I did not realize I mean I knew it was
an obsession I didn't know to the extent
that we are consuming protein the the
amount the vast amount of animal protein
that we're consuming and the just a
massive fallout from it so it just feels
all the more critical to me that we
address this protein issue that we
really parse it apart and talk about it
and we become activists so this is not
even about just changing because I think
a lot of your listeners are already on
board this is about this book being a
tool for activism like you whenever
someone says that I don't know I need my
protein I don't feel good unless I have
my protein here's here's here's a tool
that you can use you know because it is
it is an ongoing problem and it's not
going away so we have to take it into
our own hands and become protein
activists clean clean protein activism
but what if you don't want to be an
activist like people they're like I
don't want to be an activist I just want
to feel a little bit better yeah you
know well being activist for yourself
and you know most of you if you have a
partner if you have a child or just to
make it easy on yourself you're an
activist even if you if you just want to
feel good about yourself you just want
more options in your local restaurants
or in your employees cafeteria you know
it requires a certain level of activism
I was just down in Florida with my mom
and she has a local pub you know that
her condo people go to and there's
nothing to eat Debbie you know I could
eat and so for me in that moment of
activism it was I went and bought some
plant-based burgers and plant-based
cheese and we went down and we had sat
at the bar and had a beer and said
totally I'll pay for everything the
regular
Berger price but would you mind just
using my burgers throw this on the grill
and they made me an amazing cheeseburger
so that's activism so even if it's not
like I need to change this pub than I
need to you know change my community its
activism to make it easier for me for us
as individuals to eat that way requires
that we sort of speak out and and talk
to our local restaurant tours talk to
our local businesses grocery stores
request things that's what it you know
it takes that consumer demand where did
this all start for you you know I I
definitely didn't grow up this way I
love to eat you know I'm kind of I don't
know I just I started just asking
questions you know I I wrote two books
on relationships how to be more
conscious in relationships how to if you
didn't have a relationship how to find
one and if you had one how to make it
more conscious indeed and then when I
started researching another book I was
applying that consciousness that being
awakened aware to different sectors of
my life and I realized that I didn't
have any consciousness around food I had
had little glimpses here and there but
not enough to make me go deep and so I
thought wow I should know where my food
comes from and then make conscious
choices so I started looking into it
watching videos reading accounts looking
at undercover investigations and I
became deeply uncomfortable with what I
was seeing and I thought well Kath
you're a hypocrite you know if you just
keep eating the way you're eating and
you're writing about waking up and being
conscious you're a hypocrite and so I
thought if I'm going to be a writer who
talks about this stuff I have to really
challenge myself to be someone who
doesn't eat that way were you like oh my
god
like awesome no no it's like oh yeah it
was the ultimate Inconvenient Truth I
did not want to give up my favorite
foods at all and I'm kind of someone who
loves food I really love food and I love
tasty food I didn't want to I didn't
want to just be sort of this very
sanctimonious person where I'm eating a
bowl of rice and some beans or something
so I just thought I don't know how I'm
gonna do it I'm just gonna lean into it
and in the meantime I have a dog her
name was Lucy I loved her like a kid I
don't have children so I love my dogs I
hope she was on her back and I was
rubbing her belly and her legs were just
sort of you know she was just so joyful
and I could swear she was smiling and
she was wagging her tail and in that
moment I just really saw her as an
animal and not unlike any other animal
not unlike a pig or a chicken or a fish
or a cow or anything and the idea that I
could send that dog my dog into a
slaughter house the fear that she would
feel the absolute terror that she would
feel really got me and made me connect
the dots and so I that's how it kind of
started I just I for the love of my dog
really love my dog and here you are I
mean did you imagine that you would
become this sort of the vegan movement
no I I don't think I'm the face of the
vegan movement I don't wanted a face I
wanted the faces and there are many
faces that I'm proud to be part of that
village as it were the wagon mafia yeah
yeah but it's definitely a vegan there's
definitely a vegan maliki do you think
so oh yeah Wow you're part of it I don't
think so I think there is I don't know I
I mean I I have so many friends who eat
meat that you know I love and we sit
around and scoop and gossip and you know
it's we we just put that in a
compartment but they are changing I will
say I mean it's hard it's hard
for people to be around me and not eat
the food that I love because that's what
I'm serving at my house and I make sure
that it tastes really good and so it is
and you know we go out to fun
restaurants and you know I'll make sure
we go to Craig's you know so that they
can have chicken or steak and I can have
my spaghetti squash primavera and they
see that I'm eating delicious food and
I'm having the pizza but it's got vegan
cheese on it
and and it tastes just like their pizza
so it kind of influences them so little
by little you know my community is
changing too mm-hmm
but the surprising thing is that this is
my my calling which I had no idea right
this is my calling I think that that
when you kind of canvassed the whole
vegan movement there are all different
kinds of voices and they come in
different shapes and sizes your voice is
definitely one of inclusion of you know
celebrating the small victories and and
kind of providing this accessible
welcome mat for people like your relate
of people can see themselves in you your
because you're not a hippie and you kind
of live in the modern world but there
are other in there all different other
kinds of it there's very hardcore voices
there are there are sanctimonious voices
there are you know punk rock type voices
or shout and like all of that and I
think it's all great we all we need all
those different kinds of voices because
everybody has a different entry point
they're going to connect with you know
if they can't connect with you they'll
connect with you know somebody else but
I think within all of that noise there's
a lack of cohesion I think that that I
think ultimately on some level like
handicaps the movement for moving
forward and we were kind of talking
about this a little bit before the
podcast it's it's similar to national
politics like the Republicans seem to
have their talking points all in order
they know what they're gonna say they
fall into line and they get [ __ ] done
that way and the Democrats are fighting
with each other and they can't get it
together and and so ultimate
they end up hamstringing themselves from
the progress that they probably you know
all seek if they could just get past
themselves right yeah we are our own
worst enemy
we fracture and splinter off in so many
different ways in this movement and I
think that's really one of the most
unfortunate things because we need to
support each other and maybe I'm not as
hardcore as the next person but I
support that person because like you
said there are different entry points
and I also love that voice you know part
of me just I want to lift up that voice
it's great and then some other people
you know are all about being more
moderate even than me and I support that
too I think it's really important that
we're all deciding that we want to move
forward and forward movement means away
from eating animal food and toward
plant-based food there's like hardcore
there's little by little you know and I
think if we can just support each other
and opt for the better it's not the
perfect will do so much better but we we
got to stop splintering off and fighting
and because this is these are serious
times yeah we got to get Oprah
plant-based Wow are you working on her
how you gonna make that happen oh yeah I
can do that well she can move culture
yeah I know that no but she did she did
my vegan cleanse she did a she did a
vegan cleanse and she did a month-long
thing she challenged her whole company
Harpo to eat vegan which was super
successful so she's done a lot and she's
she's certainly talked about it she said
she'd never be unconscious about eating
animals again so the awareness is there
right well she had that whole thing with
the the whole lawsuit with the beef
industry over who's the guy who's in
he's the last scene of cows bearish
bad cowboy right hmm yeah well when I
when I went on Oprah the first time to
talk about this stuff all of her
producers said do not bring up the
animal stuff versus vegan stuff or
plant-based whatever you want to call it
and I was like okay I couldn't talk
about meditation I can talk about you
know all kinds of other stuff
relationships and and consciousness at
work I can talk about all of that stuff
and Oprah as Oprah is went straight to
the heart of the matter and she wanted
to talk about it because I think all of
her producers were afraid for her having
gone through that traumatic experience
with the meat industry they didn't think
she'd want to talk about it but she did
she was curious and she knows that this
is this is a real rising tide that is
only getting stronger I can't speak for
her but certainly I know that she's
interested and she's well aware of stuff
so yeah that's cool all right well we
got to wrap this up I could talk forever
but we'll keep talking for a little
while longer you want to talk about I
don't know I mean I just how's Dan doing
he's good he's good we're going to Davos
he's gonna speak at Davos so it's pretty
exciting
yeah it'd be fun we're gonna go we have
a friend over there who lives in Lugano
who is a vintner so he has fantastic
vegan want and fantastic organic wines
that are biodynamic and he's completely
plant-based so he has amazing food so
we're gonna go over and eat and drink
ourselves silly cool yeah you guys
really do live the Blue Zones lifestyle
like Dan like one thing I've noticed is
you know Dan's like very careful to like
not over commit and make sure that he
builds in you know the time that he
needs to recalibrate and enjoy his
friends yeah and that's something I have
a hard time putting into putting into
practice like I've noticed this even
this year like I don't know
burned out but like mm-hmm you work hard
take on too I take on too much and I'm
trying to get better at saying no to
stuff but finding the time to like hey
I'm just gonna go hang out with my
friends like I'm like I can't do so
George you never know look at these
mudslides I mean it could end in a split
second you know part of it is where we
live we have houses all around us all
you have to do is walk outside and
you're gonna run into somebody and
that's you know kind of a nice automatic
social situation you don't necessarily
have to have dinner with someone but you
run into someone in the street and you
have a conversation so I think that
naturally lends itself to that kind of
living situation you know with the
proximity to other people so you have an
automatic social thing then someone says
though you want to just hey I'm gonna go
hiking do you want to go with me or
things just kind of pop up yeah so you
live you know yeah like I have to make
an effort you have to make more of an
effort and and that effort involves
quite a bit of driving so for me to just
like hey let's have lunch yeah like
that's a four and a half hour a day you
know it's like yeah exactly it's like I
can't do that you know like oh well come
over to my hello that's too far I'm not
driving all the way I got it totally
definitely come up hangouts it over and
I was like that sounds amazing and I'm
like but I don't know how I can make
that no I know I'm like I could do that
but then there's no podcast happening
this week you know so I'm trying to
balance that I really take your house
and you know we're gonna be gone for a
couple weeks take our go live at your
house meet our neighbors see it's very
social up there yeah you walk outside
and people want to know how you're doing
what you're up to the farmers market
there isn't sound so good it's so good
yeah it's really good but that that
day-to-day interaction is really nice
you know and by the way our neighbors
you know they come over we have happy
hour we're totally in a happy hour
and we'll just you know every once in a
while we'll just put out a text to the
neighbors hey you guys want to come over
for happy hour and we'll have some
delicious you know
cheese whether it's you know Srimati
cheese or if it's kite hill or something
and you know hummus and it's like share
the love like this is this is our little
community like let's be social and and
it's important it's really important you
got you got to play more you got a yeah
I know it intellectually and then
putting into practice it's like and you
know I wouldn't characterize myself as a
workaholic but I'm definitely driven you
know and I think there's and like I've
been thinking about you know the ego
piece and that like okay what are you
really doing and like what is this all
about
yeah and I mean like where is your heart
like taking honest inventory of where
you're at and I and I and so I've been
doing that and that's been a kind of an
interesting you know insightful journey
into the soul and as part of kind of
that exercise I watched this documentary
Jim and Andy have you seen that
documentary yet oh man you know watch it
really it's a documentary about Jim
Carrey during the course of making the
Andy Kaufman movie oh yeah man on the
moon Wow and it's fascinating and
basically you know that he recognized
that like this was the opportunity of a
lifetime for him to portray this person
who had meant so much to him and he
decided to go all in and not not it and
it's sort of like he hired a crew to
follow him around during the process of
making this movie like a
behind-the-scenes crew and he approaches
it from a method perspective but to ask
him he would say no I wasn't doing like
a method acting job Andy literally
walked into my body and I became Andy
and Tony Clifton and I just exuded that
his psyche through the process of making
this movie in a very kind of spiritual
way and it's unbelievable to watch Wow
and how disruptive he was to everybody
because he never broke character and he
was
is obnoxious you know this obnoxious
person and to be frank like Jim Carrey's
never been the same he's never been the
same since that and the footage of this
is inter spliced with a very long
interview with Jim in current day in
which he reflects over the course of his
career from somebody who was very
ambitious you know he wrote himself that
10 million dollar check and then
achieved that very much a a master a
master at manifesting in his life to
come to this place on the other side of
it to say you know I I'm here to tell
you that like being rich and getting
everything you want is not the solution
to whatever ails you and he's been on
this deep spiritual quest to find peace
within himself
and it's very interesting and it's made
me reflect on my own journey and the
attachment like that I have like the
ambition that I have attached to what I
do
and it's like it's made me realize how I
have at times undervalued like those
things that are the most important that
and the whole point in saying that is
that I notice in you and in the way Dan
carries himself that he's not unaware of
that and that he does prioritize that
and and I can see that in you know who
he is and how he behaves and how he
carries himself and how genuine he is
with everybody that he meets mm-hmm
well that's true he is but you know give
I would say give yourself a break
because you wouldn't have achieved what
you've achieved if you didn't have that
drive and ambition and you know just
that crazy sort of dedication and
devotion to whatever you were doing
whether it was the Ultraman challenge or
starting your podcast and you know
growing that I think that's it takes a
certain amount of that but then you get
to a level and it's like okay I can I
can actually now fold in some meaningful
time with friends I can actually do
stuff that's not super you know
important I can just kind of have fun I
can just mess around
that's when the ideas come you know when
you just work work work and I said in my
book and and in the acknowledgments I
said to Dan I said let's just go sit on
the balcony and and drink wine for a
little while you know cuz it's like I
I've been working really hard and
writing takes a lot of energy so when
you just give yourself the permission I
don't mean really like we're gonna sit
in the balcony and drink wine but I mean
metaphorically let's take a break and
that's when the ideas come that's when
the inspiration comes you know when
you're not looking for it when you're
just daydreaming or my thing is dancing
I love dancing you know by myself or at
a party or whatever not in any
professional way not in a way that I'm
following steps but like just have fun
just relax and that's when the next step
shows that yeah yeah I'm gonna let go
yeah cool all right well we do have to
wrap this up but maybe you can leave us
with some helpful tools or advice for
somebody who's like okay it's 2018 I've
written I've listened to you know 300 of
Rich's podcasts and now I'm fine like
Cathy put me over the top like I'm ready
to go like what do I do
tell me where to go what should I okay
protein whatever mm-hmm what's next I
would say start crowding out some of
your favorite meals don't make it hard
on yourself
just you know start with your regular
fare so if you're having you're used to
having a burrito
you know beef burrito do black bean
burrito if you're used to having you
know pizza with sausage try a
plant-based pizza with sausage and you
know vegan cheese just try to sort of
crowd out the stuff that you're used to
having with a plant-based alternative
and do a smoothie smoothies are really
good they're so easy to you just throw
in some frozen fruits and frozen
vegetables
you know some flax seeds maybe some
protein powder see how good you feel and
just not not to worry about doing this
stuff perfectly just lean into it get
started crowd out the old stuff with it
with the cleaner versions of the
proteins and you'll find your what
you'll find your way I hear you
it's good advice all right well it's all
in the new book clean protein you
actually have like a massive recipe
section in here too so yeah
46 yeah it's like you have it it really
does like condense everything down
you're like here's food policy here's
everything that's going into how they
market these animal products to you
here's what's going on environmentally
here's what's going on with the clean
meat movement here's how plant proteins
impact your body versus animal proteins
you know and you go through all the
various diseases cancer obesity type 2
diabetes Alzheimer's even which we
didn't even talk about it's great I
think to be super helpful for people
it's a great like entry point to kind of
step into this and go oh here's all your
questions answered and why so thank you
thank you rich thank you loved hiding
with you awesome so if you want to
connect with Kathy Kathy Freston on
Twitter and Instagram not the best place
is your website mm-hmm yep Kathy Preston
calm awesome
yeah else thank you gratitude fun have
fun in Switzerland that'll be cool we
have one from have a glass of wine for
me thank you
all right well all right Kathy peace
Cheers Lance